[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fearless put of ioannina please hop in
especially Nadi's Bhutto janina's face
everybody affinities loggias nemesis my
lineage as Vietnamese like when action
dispatches women sir they as complete
them it's like when ox on this budget
more than ever media to this doctor who
enter in authorities are we school nima
minimally likely one Wonderland Alice
Moloch jihadi John Paris model Rasta man
of Charlie's they a sponge ways for
chair for the people there is burning
the party business that whoo honking one
of the beers everybody open audience no
js' women since I'm in a phase everybody
like when ox on dispatch it is honestly
blows blood no Domino go Oh JavaScript
run D show any browser any size rope on
any device the biggest thing already
still we go gusano c++ no Java no go
JavaScript run D show
all right ready to start
[Applause]
[Music]
hello whoa so many people
hey uh with the nested loops onion for
you I'm Khalil
Boris Martin yeah you might have seen us
this morning or one-and-a-half years ago
at this very place and we want to tell
you how this entire thing was made and
there's a story to it and I won't tell
the story so the year was 2014 and I
gave a talk at chess cons about Web
Audio for music production and live
performances and there was this part in
this talk where was actually performing
music and this is all look like
[Music]
[Music]
I don't remember that load okay so what
he saw was just me dabbling on an iPad
and I had no idea how to make music I
bootlegs jay-z Linkin Park they didn't
sue me what's great and but at that time
I had a much bigger dream and I was the
free guy
their drums and they taught me to use
software so the problem is neither do I
have three people capable of doing that
including me nor do I have the MIDI
instruments nor do I have the software
so that was kind of a foreshadowing of
what happened and so after that I had a
plan the plan was find band members by
MIDI instrument and write the software
so just as I was just browsing Twitter a
couple of weeks later and then I saw
this one tweet by Khalil he's like Oh
before I was the developer I was
requisitioned check it out this is me so
let's check it out
[Music]
whoa yeah now it's like I have to have
to collaborate with this guy he knows
how to make music and he has a voice
that sounds good so meet the ill
inspector okay so this is just a little
story time so I was doing music before I
was working at the developer so I was
like like four years or so it's just
like touring in Europe and doing like
dancehall but living in Leipzig there
was a label there and actually so this
video was actually shot in Japan because
there was at some point there was this
Japanese guy he wrote as an email saying
hey we would like to release an album or
something into it okay great so we
recorded an album for him and this track
actually made for him as a request
because he said in Japan they loved
poopa son who was like hmm he's like a
foundation dancehall reggae artist and
so I made a song about him and we shot
this video over they were in Japan for a
week to do like promotions and stuff
like that and that's how it kind of was
traded and actually was my greatest hit
I would say what so the cool thing was
when I was talking to Khalil he actually
told me well I have this brother Shiva
in the background he's actually a music
producer I was like that is great so let
me count I need three people me Khalil
and the guy who actually knows how to
make music it's like yeah got the bad
memories then I just had to buy media
instruments and we just bought I just
bought like one of these very sturdy
very great has a lot of buttons that
means you can do a lot of things I
thought I had no idea like really so
they call got the MIDI instrument just
have to write the software writing
software is easy right I mean we all
know that it takes a week but should we
really look like a huge music production
app for this just to perform a task on
knowing that it's like a couple of weeks
before Jays Khan's probably not also
what kind of music do we actually want
to make so we reach out to
the date comes organizers like hey what
kind of performance were you thinking of
and Martha was like be creative we trust
you
our excellent hands great so yeah we
because I'm from Berlin they're from
Stuttgart so we met up at Kelly's house
and it's this is you okay yeah so that's
where like we had our first meeting and
we're basic city we're trying to figure
out what we're going to do so we told
Boris words we need music boards like
okay I got music and was like cool so
like because Boris has been doing music
since forever and so he had like a bunch
of beats lying around and we didn't have
a lot of time so we had to there was not
really time to do a whole new beat and
so I guess so we chose one of his that
was unreleased and we liked it so we we
decided on the music first and then we
were like okay what are we going to do
like we have to do something in the
browser like just music not enough so so
we so the thought basically came up I
don't know who had it or whatever but
like we're thinking okay we're going to
take talks I mean I think what you know
like take some interesting snippets and
then trigger them on the music in the
browser like the video has to play in
the browser the music has to be played
in the browser and everything needs to
be triggered by as the the pads
basically right so so basically sorry so
this was basically how it worked we had
sorry we had the music running and we
were triggering just like random
snippets that we just cut out of the
YouTube videos and we're just trying
around stuff like this
the music in the background triggering
sniffing and so this was going on that
weekend and we were just triangle for
two days we're trying out stuff back and
forth and and that weekend we kind of
laid the groundwork for all of it and
then I would track see just me
performing over the beat so had some
lyrics
ready yeah okay what and this is
basically I'm just going to go to this
one okay so and then this video the last
one was us just before the conference we
had everything kind of ready the video
the videos were cut to a certain so that
you can see the speaker's really big and
then we had Boris also put a filter over
the video and so that was the first
iteration and and then and actually this
took like weeks and weeks of meeting up
with each other
arranging the snippet so that it kind of
makes sense that it's funny
and so like Dorothy and me were meeting
once a week or so for a while and Boris
was kind of yeah we were just trying to
make sense out of the snippets we had
and huh and we were trying to make sense
we're trying to make it look good and
actually Jana was programming the
software the whole time like there was
lots of little things that need to be
figure out like how can we because
because the videos needed to be instant
like when you press the button it just
needs to book happen right away it needs
to be synced on the music and everything
so there was a lot of crazy stuff that
when I'm sure you're going to talk about
this in a minute and so this is actually
practicing the day before the conference
2015 in our hotel room you can see the
venue right there just going through the
whole thing
okay that was us doing sound check the
day before and yeah and now young with
the software so yeah the software is
really easy right
so it just has to read MIDI data that
this thing sends a thing to your browser
and you like are cool these are events
but this is what the data looks like
that this thing is trying to communicate
with you felt like the movie the arrival
like you have to kind understand what
does computer is talking to you it's
like all of these numbers you have to
make sense like what is the position
what is like did it get pressed or not
and is to figure out all of these you
have to read the midi document for this
thing and I was like oh I didn't know
that why why did I god well that just
takes like two weeks and then what you
have like you come up with like an idea
okay so for the first row I want to have
this video played this and then that
video played you come up with like an
idea it's kind of happy but the thing is
so you have a video and videos usually
have like a video feed and an audio feed
and you kind of want to have like the
audio desync with everything so you have
to kind of like split them up again to
make put like your text on it and
everything
and then you have to kind of make like
the video still be snappy because how do
you play a video without a delay in the
browser like using the video tag to you
a just to video element dot play do you
see preload and then play or do you see
use an obscure heck and then call play
on the thing a what be yet see so it
kind of hacky so you have to load the
video in an era buffer make a blog out
of it with the correct mind type
otherwise it doesn't know it's a video
and then it's the greatest thing ever
create an object URL out of this massive
video which is really bad for RAM usage
but we didn't care
this is the only thing that makes like
pushing a button and then being it
isn't there possible all the other ones
have like a lot of delay which I'm
probably sure we would have never heard
but the person actually pushing the
button really tells it so we needed this
and yes so the cool thing is you do the
same for all the elements you have
someone who's good at pushing buttons
that guy and yeah yeah JJ's called
opening performance software this war
it's always more as we know the videos
were pre-rendered so we just had videos
with the effects on it out of like
render it the beat was in life performed
actually we just pushed the button and
then the music was playing nobody
noticed that was great but if we only
had more time we would have done it all
life so that was 2015 so we had a nice
tune right so we had a pretty
overwhelming performance like it's kind
of like our little secret with multi for
like a couple of weeks you couldn't talk
about this like all giddy giddy nobody
know we can know about this so the the
response was great like we got so so
much great feedback and I can tell you
like before the talk or before the
performance
listen Foster syndrome thing that also
applies for music performances
especially if you don't know anything
about music it's a very bad so yeah we
donated in T story yeah so made the
nested loop t-shirts so do you have the
thing loaded up yeah and many people
wanted the t-shirt we produce the Trisha
for the yeah that's right and so we made
the story fine thing I wanted to have
selfies from everybody so anybody who
has a teacher please you didn't send a
selfie our way I want to have the selfie
so I can put it into the story flower
okay so there's a lots of lots of people
who it's Allah
and this yeah lots of cool people with
the t-shirt and yeah so we so we saw
those peace t-shirts on t spring and we
we made a little bit of money so the
margin on the t-shirt was very low the
little money thing was like 300 dollars
or something like that we all gave away
for good causes and so they're like a
hundred dollars for caught her cause or
something like that so we didn't make
any money from it but so yeah so we all
felt really good and it's nice to see a
lot of people with the t-shirt out here
today it was really cool yeah they're
all know that was a break a J's cones
break and then we got up again to step
it up a notch they didn't react to that
but we felt we had to do that and this
time I really wanted to build a real
piece of software not this like six
weeks heck that lived on this obscure
video hack that is still in the
production software now so this time we
actually started a six months ago
already like as you can see in October
the first two commits and then we worked
along the way on that and so 2015 what
the thing did was push a button it it
did a thing and in 2017 you push a
button and it does 10x things so we kind
of thought who who does know like which
one is which there by the way this is
this is our Tech's take an order to
guess which one is redox react and
electron so we thought like the one and
a half year that has like everybody was
talking about react Redux an extra ones
we don't we have to make a software to
make music with all of these tools so
that we can dog feed or industry
gullible so the app actually looks
amazing
you will see later on so you have like
this is like a representation of the
physical pad and then on the side you
can see like what kind of clip you want
to play and all these things whatever
you want to attach to it and so what was
really cool about this is you can import
export project set up so the thing
before was whenever Boris wanted to have
like a button on a different thing there
he is he was calling me and I was like
okay I'm going to do this
push that to github so that he can work
on it an hour later this was horrible so
now we can like exported zip and import
and all these things it has perfect
timing in there before that we had like
a lot of human errors mainly mine and
now there's a computer taking care of
the timing as in if you push the button
too early before the beat it can make
this wait a bit and I click like it will
be perfect to the beat so the problem is
if you're too late we cannot take that
because JavaScript doesn't have time
travel yet let's see see see 39 was
what's up this time we actually do have
live music I mean you didn't notice
before there was no like music but and
also the we had a life video shoulders
as you saw this morning but yeah this is
like technical stuff let's let's hear
how like a beat it's made so high so we
this time we wanted to make an original
beat or I want to do that and first up
the guys listen to all the talks and
they gathered snippets for me and then
I'd about 150 snippets about stuff that
I don't really understand and so the
first thing we have to do we when we
start from scratch we have to find
something that we can build on so
basically I was just trying out stuff
like so it means that some of the code
that's running now in angular 2 it and
so it means that some of the code that's
running now in angular 2
more food and so it means that the flow
of doodle and played around with that I
had to pitch function with this
controller which is the Ableton push and
I just played around and then at some
point we had a chorus which is as you I
think all know by now
people got JavaScript this one the
people got mad JavaScript and then I
started to build a beat around it
basically to have yeah pretty pretty
simple
yeah built built bent around it with the
bassline drums first things pretty loud
everything yes kick 8-bit kick as well
and then just build on top of it make a
bass line and some melody and then we
just need some people talking JavaScript
people got that people got bad you got
JavaScript people got bad yeah that's
basically what I did thank you
ah yeah so 2017 brought a lot of changes
and an event member yeah you might have
noticed I mean we kind of said it as
well Martin joined the band and was
doing live lights and the tech behind
that is pretty amazing and please tell
us how he did it
yeah technically and more roadie than
proper band member but so can we can we
switch to develop to see you know all
right of course
[Music]
all right so um who was here last year's
last time Jess cogs oh that's quite just
few people but I gave a talk at just of
you 2015 and there I kind of like left
through how to control professional
light equipment using javascript won't
go until that much detail here but yeah
that's basically what I did is a light
show Jas but if you will there you
already know that it was actually light
shall see is there because everything
you saw this morning considering the
light show was entirely written in CSS
with proper CSS killed was interpreted
by my browser in real-time and
everything I did was just toggling um
classes on parent element using the same
here so each of these buttons has a
class name attached to it and if I
prefer the class gets added if I release
it the class gets removed and there are
some buttons that act as switches where
I can just press class gets edit press
again class gets removed so um this was
basically how the lecture was controlled
so in order to do that we'll see us as
we need some HTML to operate on and lose
basically how that looks I have devices
and I give them class names I have some
special attributes like type and channel
which is the technical stuff and it
turns out browsers just don't care as I
don't know the tag name they simply
treat them just like HTML so all fine
here I know I can use proper custom
element if you sure but - neato so um
the CSS I have a color property I have a
brightest property and I define an
animation over brightness on color the
color is pretty simple there's something
that CSS a way to provide the brightness
is yeah something that I just made up
and considering more complex devices
like those here they can move around and
stuff like that there's lots and lots of
functions and they simply made up CSS
property names for each of their
features and all of them can be animated
so I add some JavaScript errors in this
case I would just pull the get computed
style of all the devices notes and I get
the computed style returns
conveniently of the current animation
state - including any animation and
finish those can really running so I'm
back there I had good Calavera I get the
brightness value and I sent them over
the DMX protocol side note and DMX is
the serial protocol that is used by each
and any piece of professional lighting
hardware there is so I can be pretty
sure if I come to any venue they will
have a DMX system and my DMX interface
will completely work with that in theory
so I'm the only thing I will mention
about DMX now is that each and every
device has a unique and yeah very
specific pre-configured address which is
what you saw on the HTML earlier so the
back to the spheres have code there's
obviously two problems with us first of
all we can't just make up CSS property
names because they will simply get
ignored by the browser get computed
style won't return them so that's a
no-go
only now we have custom properties so if
I add two dashes everything works fine
right yeah except that custom properties
together the transitions and animations
currently do not work as intended in any
browser so I have to find some way
around this and this is this nice little
hack instead of just using my properties
like brightness can - whatever else I
simply choose one of the properties that
can be animated like left right top
bottom margin padding whatever anything
that can be animated I can use as a
replacement so in this case I chose like
left for brightness as a replacement and
it can animate the left property and
yeah everything worked like intended so
the only thing I need to do in order to
get that done a little hack which is I
pass the CSS now using the rework path
or then I do some ASC transforms
introduce the custom properties
introduced for animated properties that
introduces fall backs and then serialize
the CSS again injected into the page it
gets applied to my device node then in
order to read all that out I have to
reverse all that so I have to use get
computed I could get in both cases left
property value and apply it to the DMX
devices as brightness in this case this
works pretty well only
all those doesn't really help to prepare
a light show simply because there's
never enough time to prepare if I only
have more time right so the last
comfortable I do that as I have like at
best two hours preparation time at the
band you're being connected to the DMX
devices and as it is I'm rarely
connected to such huge setups of DMX
divisor so most of the two hours are
spent fixing bugs and then I have maybe
like half an hour to program the light
and this is not something I want to live
with and especially for this conference
I needed to come with samples come up
with something else
so I had from the awesome people that
were planning a layout of this
conference I guess it was like a month
ago or something like that these 3d
images of how the stage is supposed to
look and it's pretty much like that now
right so I started to think about what I
could do if I threw together basically
any software that I could find and the
end result is this so I have to build a
Mexican which is basically just coq10
for lecture and the nice thing about DMX
channels that I have those runner which
usual 3GS and a frame will provide me
for the proper preview of what it might
look like on stage turns out it doesn't
really look like that because obviously
my colors are much brighter than the
real ones but yeah um to the left top um
you see the HTML or devices panel those
of the list of all the devices are found
over in the main hall so we have like
can a lot of these these spotlights here
and this LP the short for light panels
will be 2 by 2 meters panel there's 35
of them yeah I simply just got all the
channel numbers and so on from the
people at the venue when I arrived here
two days ago and yes that and this here
you'll see a CSS code that was actually
able I'd show so am a lot of mixer and
configuration basic settings things like
that and then there are the a1 is simply
on the top left bottom button and of
oppressive it will just run the color
animation that I defined there yeah and
finally they also got there was this
moving have spotlights which we can also
toggle and trigger and yeah
so nice to think about them just you
didn't see that because in order to see
this moving have spotlights you need a
lot of haze on or smoke in the room and
it's not good at the beginning of a
conference so that's at it looks much
better here reality bite if I only have
enough time so um all of this and don't
judge me about this twelve megabytes of
JavaScript and it really uses everything
barriers basically so I have the code
Moreau editors Thanks for writing them I
know he's here somewhere
I used that Jes was actually actually an
ASM compiled version of look at CSS or
look that for something like that so I'm
using a fmjs as well I'm using a frame
from Mozilla what makes it really easy
to build these virtual reality
applications using three.js left here
and all of the other Souls III think
none of you also saw these libraries
ever thought it would be used that way
but thank you very much
[Applause]
and finally I left out all of the
details so if you want to know more I
will probably be giving slightly more
technical introduction and the community
area at large is due tomorrow
so thank you very much oh and one thing
we're going to do both now right we're
going to do this now oh there's more
that's always more that's a couple of
announcements okay
ah yeah yeah it's amazing yeah you can
show the t-shirt so we have t-shirts
again as you can see and also hoodies
actually stuff so there's a new
teespring campaign tool actually
teespring campaign so there's this one
and then this one so this one says
people got mad JavaScript this one says
people got JavaScript and has all the
speakers that we used on and so these
campaigns we need at least 20 people who
want a t-shirt so that it gets shipped
and it's just after three days it just
restarts so if you want a t-shirt get
twenty people together and get a t-shirt
or hoodie it's not like that
and so the URLs how you find it so
quickly people got mad jx1 and people
got mad js2 okay
that's the one announcement the other
one is you can stream and download the
track for fries on soundcloud so that's
just what with the URL again SoundCloud
become slash nested - loops people got
mad JavaScript alright so if you want to
listen to it on the go and stuff cool
stuff is there is there more oh yeah
everything is open sourced you can find
all the stuff like the code this snippet
I don't have the snippet all I'll get
but the artwork and everything on github
you can play around with it you can do
stuff with it you can remix it whatever
it's all open source
alright that's it
shall we do it again so this is just to
show you that it's an actual software
that runs on electron because we didn't
change the logo there we also kind of
use a hack where that's like an express
DEP inside this electron app just to get
MIDI support or something I know it was
late and it's six months ago I didn't
want to change it so let's let's put up
this thing listen everything's loaded
don't some four screen mode also to the
to the Ableton people you have to press
tab to go to the session view and yeah
let's go yeah
[Applause]
hi hi hahaha will will okay yes no no
okay I can just feel the excitement
we're all real okay
yes no no okay I did you feel the
excitement
Oh over return to demonstrate what a
merry hope over return to JavaScript
what a nice pop over we turn to
JavaScript
what are you how do we turn to
JavaScript
what are you why did you rent Angela :
well people got mad when I put it all in
one file
why'd you write modular code well people
got mad when I put it all in one file
[Music]
people goddamn people got people goddamn
you got people goddamn people that
people goddamn people can't people got
that you got people got an up so I'm
gonna say things which are going to be
shocking and hurtful
which are not directed at you at all
javascript is a hot mess all they can do
is add forth and they're busy doing
that's the worst API ever developed in
history that's why the gold standard is
on now the problem with now the problem
with is everybody knows right with JSON
that when you get a huge payload from
the server what is in there
what what what what is in there I don't
know we gained something that not
because free shaking what huh I didn't
really get that reshapes free free shake
because we need small turn but no one
understand it's tradition it's just some
generic information you know not scary
at all
higher-order question you know the smell
scary at all which ends with a function
in function etc you know scary at all
flow of data employed when helpless is a
program kind of like the concepts of
time or return to the scoreboard
JavaScript because of that will be the
goodness has unexpectedly become the
world's most popular functional
programming you want to do everything
with there's more there's totally more
there's always more
[Music]
mm everybody happy not players fearless
Brittani not me I mean our sales
everybody of minorities loved us vanity
tight enough a KL concrete I mean like
wear socks on this budget monitor
dummies like when Hawks on this budget
more than the media you need anybody's
harvest 11:00 in the morning
lastly what $1 Kalevala mr. Collins
murder russamano college
they are unfaithful cheer about key
person is sterling holidays nested loops
multiple of the day everybody will be
bodies Raja has vanity toy innovate am i
becoming liquid option budget penalty
Blatz Blatz know Java novo JavaScript
run easily brother anytime I needed it
existing already to we go whoa miss uh
no C++ no Java no go JavaScript run D
show any browser any sense
run on any device the biggest thing
already still we grow
thank you
[Applause]